you were at the game just tell us about
your memories of the match and your
feelings about it now as a survivor well
it's it's very mixed feelings you know
today my thoughts are with the families
as always I hope that now they can begin
to get some peace in 27 years of mental
torture I mean [ __ ] for me and for my
two sons and nephew with me on the day
you know it began as a typical classic
outing to a Liverpool match in a in a
cup run and beautiful sunny April day
going over the pen inés arriving at
Leppings Lane to find it seething and
out of control by the turnstiles with no
effort made to stream the supporters and
get them into lines and check the
tickets outside and very frightening I
mean the police actually were helping
people to climb over the walls into the
ground you know but my two sons and
Matthew and Nick and my nephew Karl went
on ahead into the ground because I
didn't like the crush I held back they
went on eventually clearly after the
gates had opened it could calm down and
I went through I didn't know anything
had happened untoward bought a program
and then a man came rushing up to a
policeman he was standing by me and said
you've got to do something this kid's
dying in there
so I made haste up the steps to the to
the seating area above the central pens
be just behind the girl very good seats
couldn't get down to the seats the
aisles were crowned I could see car
lights at the front helping to pull
people up from below we've seen those
scenes on the television and I had to
clamber over the seats to get down to
the to the row near the front where we
had the seats and the game had stopped
by then
almost immediately I saw them bringing
lifeless shapes of bodies out into the
into the penalty area to the six-yard
box and I said to one of my sons I think
that person may be dead and then another
person I think they may be that they're
lifeless they you know maybe they're and
then the tunnel he appealed for medics
and nurses to help so I went immediately
down the back of the steps again
presented myself to a police officer and
said who do I report to what do I do he
said of no idea and then it the complete
chaos became apparent and I finished up
having to initiate the triaging of the
casualties because the police were
beginning to take people out of various
severity z-- to hopefully the ambulances
arriving because they at that time I
think there was only one ambulance there
so I and others who arrived or the
doctor and some nurses systematically
sorted the casualties and sent them off
the ones who really needed to be got to
hospital quickest and we did that and we
did that round and round the rows of
people who were leaning against the
fence until it was all over and I was
then asked to certify dead and I by one
of the policemen I certified six people
dead wrote out impromptu death
certificates with sheets ripped out from
an exercise pad and pinned to the
garland swithed safety pins there was no
ID on on five of the six these are the
days before mobile phones the day before
days before bank cards even and and then
it all likewise I went to the gymnasium
to see what was going on I went twice or
the other but I was surprised to find in
the gymnasium photographs of lots of
Liverpool supporters on the wall that
was a kind of rogues gallery of people
they were expecting to go cause trouble
and it gave you an insight into the
mindset of the police on the day they
saw it as being
about hooliganism about crowd control
abouts Kali's about scousers and all of
that and then at a certain point then I
was cleared out everybody wasn't a
police officer it was cleared out of the
gym they closed the doors and I suspect
that's when the cover-up started when a
narrative that was presented to mrs.
Thatcher and Bernhard Ingram on the
Sunday morning began to be formulated
when I was going back to Leppings Lane
from the GM I met a young policeman
absolutely distraught him in tears and
he said to me the senior officers
they're going to blame us now it was all
their fault but they're going to blame
us because ironically they didn't blame
the junior officers they blamed the
supporters and I got in my car with the
boys drove back to Liverpool went into
Radio City where I used to be regular
health broadcasts because I knew all the
people were you guys and I went on the
evening news and told the story as I had
experienced it because I knew it was
going to be necessary for somebody like
myself a professional to tell the story
to make sure the right story was what
was out there
subsequently Lord Justice Taylor in his
report said that I was totally
irresponsible to criticise the emergency
response he said that I made three
claims that the emergency services were
slow to arrive that there was inadequate
equipment on those ambulances when they
arrived and that if the emergency
response had been better lives might
have been saved Taylor says that I John
Ashton was wrong on all three counts I
lived with that for 24 years 25 years
that I was professionally telling fibs
lying whatever misleading about the
response and you know all that but so I
had to live with that but the important
thing today is the families you know
I've said this many times that if you
lose a loved one a parent a grandparent
when their time has come
that's terrible thing to happen and we
all have to live through that if you
lose somebody through an accident that
must be many times worse but if you lose
somebody through a disaster like this
that could have been avoided if all
these agencies have done their job
properly the FA the engineers the club
the police the ambulance service if
they'd done their job properly it could
have been avoided and then it's followed
up by lies cover-up innuendo character
assassination and so on how do you come
to terms with that how do you come to
terms with that I just hope that after
today the families can begin to get
peace we've got a lot of the facts we
still don't know the level of
involvement of the Cabinet Office we
wait the appearance of the Cabinet
Office papers in a couple of years time
I hope they don't disappear I hope
they're not redacted but we need to know
as well what the involvement of the
government departments of the day and of
Downing Street was in orchestrating the
narrative about what was supposed to
have happened but today's the day to
think about the 96 today's today that I
think about young Phil Hammond who
played football in the same school team
that's my boy Nick and who I and some
other men took the team to to Rennes in
France for a week playing footballer I
think of Phil and I think of Phil's
family and for me that brings the
enormity of these 96 to reality and I
have trouble holding back the tears and
I think about them and I think about the
breakdown of trust with it with the
police force who are supposed to police
by consent and the shocking lack of
shame of people who've lied over all
these years and some of whom still will
not admit their responsibility I think
of that
and I worry about that about this
country about its leadership and about
the fact that people will not accept
responsibility when things go wrong I
hope this is a watershed and I hope one
of the legacies of Hillsboro will be
that when things go wrong people put
their hands up and say that they are
responsible